hello everybody hope you are all having
a great
day i think everything is good i made
some small adjustments to the camera and
i was trying to figure out
whether or not i should turn this on and
however i placed it just like
one side of my face would look super
bright and the other side would just
look
um well not really
lit so i think for now this is good
if later it's needed i can probably
figure that out too
uh today we're sitting in a different
spot in the house because oh boy the
weekend that i had
so i will be telling you more about it
when we hit some stopping points but
this is
one of my favorites ever games
and so i don't want us well i mean
there's a high chance
many of you will already be familiar
with it
since it was a world championship match
so you know more people know about us
sorry
uh this was the world championship in
chennai 2013
and magnus won this one and he has been
a reigning champion
since um but yeah i believe this was
game
nine yeah
all right all right so
i think this was one of the coolest ones
especially because well to be fair
i think my personal favorites from
magnus's
series of wins is when he
uh won against nakamura in 2013 don't
get me wrong
i'm a huge knuckle fan but that game
whoa
that was just awesome that i i actually
i was thinking about have i done that
yet or not so i had to go check in the
video series and found that find that
i have done that i'm sure we can pull up
the link
for that too that was a very fun one
that one
is my most favorites magnus win of all
times
still haven't managed to find another
one to beat it
so we're gonna start off this one uh
let's go ahead so magnus was black in
this game and that
remember this is seven actually uh eight
years ago so
don't um don't underestimate
young magnus all right
oh i see the chat is also warming up
lovely
okay yeah so i also personally play this
opening
i play nimzo indian i actually think i
started playing in 2013 as well
i kind of always liked it i thought it's
such a fun
little like i'm a big fan of the center
however in these type of games
uh it just i don't know it just feels
way too good not to play like this not
to
um not to
be a little sneaky when it comes to the
opening
like from the white side i have to do e4
i just can't like
i've tried ready i've tried london
london is still fine but
i am i'm just an e4 girl i like it
it's straightforward it just goes
very just fast-paced
i love it i can't help myself sorry
sorry for the disappointment um
like even today if you there will
probably be more pictures up for it
but we the the chess club had the um
chess cops events where like
we went to me and alejandro and bunch
but actually dominguez showed up for a
minute or two too it was so cool
a bunch of the cool guys and a lot of
the club
staff were there and there was great hot
dogs i liked it i had two
i feel a little uh twofold but anyways
uh
even with that we were doing like a
simultaneous exhibition
but it's like i i loved e4 i was like
okay so for this one i'll do retty but
for this one i just like it was like
five e4's one recipe so anyways i'm just
blabbering at this point talking about
my love for center but guys don't forget
center matters you might not want to
attack it directly immediately but
the control of it matters all right so
um bobby blunder is not necessarily this
idea of queen c2 obviously
there's so many different ways to play
against themselves however
in this game
anand went for f3 now f3 has been known
to be pretty sharp
if my memory serves correctly i've had
some struggles with f3 against
jonathan slash and slash or i think it
was ant
caleb they both kind of played this
against me once or twice so when we had
like an inner tournament
uh in a club tournament that was a
little
hard for me to and then i kept like
trying to play different lines against
it
and um somehow i never really felt that
confident in it
anyways um one of the biggest thing to
keep in mind
is okay again i'm getting a little
sidetracked because i love talking about
openings
um so especially in these type of ninja
indians never play after no that's not
i think ben fingers could agree here
after he's fine and
so one thing is like this ideas with f
string or e3 in just
in names of indian we basically really
do
want to try and take over here if we get
the chance
and then we uh would like to do this
cool attack
around here which i also have done
a little bit of tiny pieces of video
series on it
i believe it was both youtube and twitch
we can also find that too
put the link here but the whole idea is
that this ideas with like then this like
two
super weak pawns and then i'm bringing
this
forces oops bringing his forces to go
attack them
bring this it's like so much fun and
so this idea i think is one of the
things to keep in mind
so for me whenever my opponents play e3
or f3
in my mind i'm like yes now i can
potentially start looking at this
so i try to avoid playing d5 like i
don't play this d5 that often
i prefer to do something with like c5
which is fine
but especially with f2 you have to be
more cautious because e4s could also be
coming up like d
d5 e4 it could get very very fast pace
yes thank you brian clark yeah i
remember like i think it was actually
twice that happened
um i'm quite certain one of it was caleb
because then i was giving him like a
little stink eyes like
you just beat me but i was better
carlson yeah yeah that was 2013 that's
the year that cousin became the world
champion if you didn't win it
man i think congratulations the wrong
guy about this championship
all right so f3 d5 is the strongest c5
is another there's like a bunch of other
stuff that you can just cast on and then
do this 98 or like knight h5 ideas
there's so
many many many different ways of playing
it
but that's not the point um the point is
that here
you kind of have to know uh
different different positions that you
could end up
so what type of positions you would get
in with default what type of positions
you would get in with c5 what type of
positions do it gets in with like that
night hanging
on h5 or e8 or stuff like that so that's
on you
so there is no nothing like in super
high levels yes there is like
only one best line that you have to
follow to get there
but in an even in my levels even a
little higher than my levels
it's not like that you as long as you
get a playable position and you know
where to put your pieces and what's your
plan for the middle game you'll be fine
you don't need to play the first moves
of the engine every single
move that's kind of the the one of the
biggest things i learned
all right so uh there's a question on
where
is his majesty gmp he just walked in the
kitchen
i'll tell you more about our adventures
over the weekend
um and actually yesterday too but for
now let's get a little deeper in the
game
uh there is there was something to
mention about the e3 first and it kind
of gets very similar to the
game too so let's just look at the the
game that
we have at hand d5 boom boom boom
now c5 was played i like the structure
my only problem with it
is um i can't do like
because this pawn is on d5 you can take
it so i don't have that like
weakness the two the double bond
weakness that i want to go poke at
i don't have that that's the only thing
so take
take and uh adam went for e3 now
my question from the viewers they're all
they're only at move eight
but this is not a super long game
uh the game actually ended in i want to
say 30 moves almost yeah little less
than 30 moves like 28 29 loops
so this is not a super long game so
understanding the why behind the moves
are much more important than just seeing
how it ended because we all know um
carlsen won this game it says it's right
here and then we also
know that crosstalk won this match
because well he's been the world
champion since
which was kind of interesting i do want
to know
what you guys think about the
possibility of
naka becoming the world champion
that's another fun one that i don't know
what you guys think about
all right i'll give you guys maybe
another 30 seconds
uh just make sure to type in the chat
what you want to happen
what do you think it's gonna happen it's
just like
where the pawns belong
oh bobby we need to know this is the
game that
this is a match that determined the
world champion the
reigning world champion we got to know
yeah that's also another good question
which one who do you think is gonna be
because uh it's coming up their match
it's what in like
i wanna say less than six months
coming up very soon all right but
besides that
sorry not nepal or naka um it would be
funny actually a match was in their
poncho
but first napo has to beat magnus and
then naka has to be able to challenge
that but it'll be a fun thing
so yeah yeah we're gonna try to figure
out what to do with this pawn honestly
either take
push or just ignore it and uh be fine
with the isolated pawn so that that
pawn structure right now is very very
important
we need to know what is happening for
this palm structure
lovely yeah i like c4 i think c4 is
actually the best one
now
after c4 it's kind of trying to
it's what i from what i understood this
c4 was an attempt for a magnus to kind
of throw off
anand with like a this like the sideline
that's not
very often played now
is it the bad move no um it doesn't
exactly violate like these principles to
try and keep the center
fluid now if you are um
not very familiar with center ideas i
strongly suggest for you to
well become more frequent familiar with
them especially because
for the c4 ideas when you're like seems
like you're closing up the center you
are not
really closing up the center because
this pawn still is movable
and also this is a semi-open file so we
are going to be able to
form attacks on this um
side of the board yes
i have a viewer
live viewer oh cambridge lovely all
right so
that's one thing i did want to mention
and now so now that we have a better
understanding of the pawn structure
potential future of the center what do
you think
is going to be happening with the
um with the
king what do you think is gonna happen
with the king
because that's another issue we're
definitely gonna have the short cast
though
probably gonna dummy this but this game
is both sides of the shortcast all right
the kings are that's the only way that
they're safe
so that's just kind of like a small
thing that it is
important to just keep in mind it's not
it's not like if we don't know it we're
not going to be able to play it but it's
important to
um just have that internal peace like
okay
i i know i want to um
i know i want to sorry i'm struggling in
words a little
i know i want to do the shortcast though
but the one of it is important too
okay so um without further ado let's
continue
so knight e2 where do you think this
knight tries to go probably g3 yeah
and then where not entirely sure if
there is a future for this knight from
there but
it's going to be assisting on the e4
idea so i think that's one thing that's
definitely
worth it
uh that's a very interesting idea but i
am very busy for
june feel free to send me more
information
it would be fun
so we know that's going to happen too
yep
getting the knights here pushing the
pawn so from black side this knight c6
is a must
uh castle is a must what else is a must
i'm not entirely sure what i want to do
with this bishop so i'm going to leave
it here
probably there will be some pawn
movements in the queen side but we are
not in a rush for that the one thing
that we have to decide is do we want to
do 96 first or
castle i think that's important
to try and figure out
so between castling and
knight e uh sorry not knight nice c6
sync
not my e5 that would be disastrous
so i like knight c6 more because i know
for a fact
that's right now my c6 is something that
i need
but for castle i could still wait a
minute wait a little bit
my knights like has no other place to go
besides the square
so that's not like i'm not it's not a
very hard choice to make
when it comes to this move
all right let's see what else do we have
okay okay i like this now um i'll give
you guys a small
hint because this was a very interesting
move that white made so
right now white made a very
i want to say dubious but a very
challenging move it's a very good move
and it's quite challenging for
us because then we have to come up ooh
should we take this move seriously is
this a joke
should i try to block it should i try to
attack it what should i do with it
oh so why to move what do you think
no no suggestions so far
remember how we talked about how much we
love doing long
short castles and how much we definitely
need to do short castles
well the move that white does kind of um
questions that kind of makes that the
idea that we had about
white needs to cast though then we're
gonna be like ha
seriously why it's gonna do short castle
after that
hopefully that kind of gives it away a
little bit
why am i still saying that there we go
yep g4 to me this move
was so weird and intimidating and even a
little bit more weird again
just like weird i don't know how to
explain it
but uh it's just no it's just one of
those moves that's
it's just i really hard to explain
i don't honestly i don't know if just
move g4
is something that i would want to do i
would
think of doing as white i think g4 is
um just such a
super grandmaster move that's all i can
say about it
because g4
then makes this knight g3 stronger this
knight stand
stays behind these pawns and then
these pawns can start to march the king
does stick kind of in the center
but as long as weiss doesn't voluntarily
play something like e4 and open the
center
there is no serious attack on it so
white spine on that front as well
does that make sense or is that just in
my head
yeah so now magnus decided to castle h6
is something else that i think it's
worth mentioning
but after h6 just bishop gets out then
we try to go
get the knight to a5 so we can you know
block the clue inside a little bit
and now we can castle and just continue
with i think this is also a very just
chill way to play and this was
actually a game between kasparov and
a lovely polgar in 1997.
so it was about like 15 years before
this game
this was played between the two
and i believe kasparov won that game
uh versus pogar anyway so that's one
thing that i wanted to mention that
this idea of h6 so g4 not a novelty just
to clarify
not a novelty who was white in that game
that game was a game between kusparov
and polar
which caused powerful in 1997. so after
g4
we start to as black well we gotta do
something this h6 can't be played
well can be played but has a little
bitterness to it because pogba has
already lost in it
and then there's this idea with knights
um trying to go
knight a5 knight b3 but it kind of
transposes the same thing again
so in the game magnus castle bishop g2
knight eight five and got this knight
there now
what to do black to move what to do we
are already
a little over uh i mean almost halfway
through the game so what do you think
and i mean halfway like we're at move 13
the game is like 28 moves
so what do you think is going to go
wrong in the next
well 10 moves well that's actually a
very scary thought
you know i do those thought process
sometimes like i'm just like
what's my life gonna be in next 10 years
and this
really scares me first off
will my parents be here will my cat be
here will i
be here will i have the job i want will
i have a kid
well i'm not oh it's such a just like so
much will i won't i ah
i'm gonna go back drink like tea
i hope there's still tea in 10 years
oh that was very strong teeth oh i
should probably add more water to it
okay the center is going to blow up
uh potentially
so that's the thing the king side attack
not necessarily because our pieces like
i have this ginormous knight up here so
it's gonna be something in the queen
side
[Music]
what did they stumble into oh no i was
just talking about how this game is uh
gonna like
be determined in 10 moves and it's so
weird and then i related it to
um what will my life look like in 10
years and it
kind of spiraled on bad
okay yeah so we don't want to touch the
king side king side is right now for
white
what about the queen side
can we do anything with the queen sides
still in school that is highly likely so
that's actually very painful that's i
think
oh no i felt depressed okay
yeah um uh good to know i i have
well at least you guys have confidence
to me that i'll manage to get grades and
stay in school that's good and yes it is
b5 lovely
yes so i want to ask you a question
why aren't we taking over here
it's would get rid of the two bishop why
why aren't we doing that
it's it's not it's not a calculation of
it's more like a
chess knowledge type of move so i kind
of
trust you can find it
and gmp she is eating
uh i wouldn't say bad bishop but
i would say that how many moves did we
spend with the knights
knight c6 a5 b3 and take on c1
for a bishop that did not even move once
so we would like waste
four moves to just take
one bishop it's not worth it
also this knight on b3 is quite strong
that's another side of it yeah
all right i like this then we can start
pushing over there
in the game anand went for knights g3 a4
seems to be interesting as well however
in knight g3 boom a5
i believe this a5
10 year not ten years eight years ago
was a novelty
if anybody knows this to be wrong please
do correct me
but in my knowledge that is that you was
the novelty
all right what else what else do we have
that good night yeah this knight is a
good boy
so i'm gonna move it along um
the question on why not rook e8 what do
you think is
not very good to jerky eight rookie
eight was
another way that this game was played
when was this
same year between um
i actually don't know these people
uh this game anyways was played between
uh it was a game in u.s league
league in 2013 and
kind of um black king i got
two opened up and black could not really
survive it
yeah all right so at rookie hg5 then you
gotta move this knight then this push
and then it
gets too slow this knight movement is
way
too slow and by the time
black managed to get his pieces in row
for
queen side attack this king side is like
this king is like
it's like blatant it's like lake it like
lonely and naked this king is like i
just came up with the word lol
but it's like this is this is like a sad
king it's like
so alone it's like i'm feeling bad for
this king this king needs to get a pet
but yeah this this king is a sad king we
don't want sad kings
we want happy king all right but um
yeah and then like uh in this game
black panther is like getting the bishop
out even this bishop even goes from a
different way
and then oh this is just hurting my eyes
at this point
ouch honestly i don't think about magnus
going to survive this is black
and black made another mistake which was
faced by
just e6 i'm just trying to show you how
this could go
hurts my eyes check and
all right i want to actually ask you why
don't what do you think white can do
i mean white could just simply take it
over here and still win
you know there was a lot of walking
involved in my day
but my weekend my weekend was
not fun actually i did i thought i think
i
did teach on sunday so for any of you
who were here on sunday i told you that
something was stuck
in my bathroom vent and um
it's not like decomposing and i was
right
yesterday they came they opened it and
they
took the poor squirrel out it was so
just
sad and just then i had to stay
somewhere with peachy overnight
because it was too smelly here and oh my
god that was a mess
then i had to wash everything in my
apartment
because uh they didn't know what like
maybe it has a disease or something oh
my god it was just
i had seven loads of laundry i even
washed
like pillows like actual pillows not the
pillowcases
so ha yeah i had a fun weekend that was
your weekend
yeah okay yeah f6
honestly anything wins this is also
winning it makes it lessens the the
winning a little bit
but yeah you know
it was not a rat it was a poor squirrel
that apparently there are like a family
of squirrels
living in this building between the
walls so
they're still trying to figure out how
to deal with that
yeah that's an ongoing problem
oh thank you silas all right so
let's get back to the real game and i
i might vent more about this maybe
but for now i feel okay
all right so there was a real game uh
magnus did not mess with this rookie 8
stuff he played
a5 g5 and now where do we place this
knight
do we have a favorite spot well i mean
you kind of have two choices so do you
have a favorite spot
i agree e8 because with eas
you have some chances of covering up
this leaked
king yeah i like this
if you need it you might not need it
opponent might not form an attack
all right good job yeah good job
everybody if one thing the one other
tiny thing to mention if e4 we could
just take
and then just play h6 uh black is right
on time to
keep everything under control this is
this these are also potential targets
all right great great so
g5 and now a knight e8
now e4 so this move that magnus made
was a little uh like i had to
it was a little weird i'm not gonna lie
it because it was something that we
talked about earlier and we were like
nah we don't want to do this
but then magnus went ahead and do it so
what do you guys think
white uh whites to move
oh my god sorry black dude why just
played e4
hello big stretch
take the bishop exactly that's that's
the thing like
it's like we talked about it earlier and
so it seems like magnus decided that
this exchange
it's kind of necessary and so
the original plan needs to be changed
and to me
that's cool because you don't have to
stay on the same
plan but at the same time you
we talked about it we were like this
kind of loses like four tempos
yes i did the chess cups today i was
there alejandro was there
caleb was there ryan was there
dominguez showed up for a little bit uh
who else was there oh joy i was there i
saw her
it was like a big party of
just the chess pieces
and hot dogs they were amazing hot dogs
i had two
yeah we decided to take this and that's
why i'm just like ah did i just say we
don't want to do it
yeah so it was
weird because carlson is like losing
basically
three temples and
they were like we just slipped like
knight c6 a5 b3 and take that we did
four moves but um
yeah it's let's let's keep looking i'll
ask you in like few moves if you still
think
it's really matters the next move so
it's not just this move this single move
on its own looks weird
but if you can find this move that what
black did right
now then we can actually
see like oh okay that kind of makes
sense
yeah the other problem was that
i was storing stuff for one of my
friends
and just to be safe for both me and him
i was like you know what
i'm gonna like buck spray everything
like the the rocks the catches and
everything
and it turned out there were um i was
hosting a stray cat once or twice
and it had fleas so i had to
make sure she didn't have fleas take him
to vet get him checked get him medicine
wash everything vacuum clean everything
wash myself
wash like everything like there was so
much washing i can't feel my fingers
fingertips are a little gone at the
moment but that was fun
great wolf me too
yeah rook a6 nice one rook a6
it is and i think rookie 6 is why we can
be like okay so we we can kind of make
sense of why we took it
because now this pawn is weak the stroke
is very strong
it's not just that we're playing in the
queen side where we're kind of
shifting the focus between queen and
king side and
not just that either
now what do you think white should do i
think uh
considering f4 is a fair suggestion but
is it the right time
oh thank you joe they were very lovely
there was one little girl that i thought
she was very talented
but i didn't get to finish my game with
her
i hope she joins our camps and gets more
involved
exactly i think it's time to get some of
the heavy pieces involved too
all right so what do you think white's
gonna do we just played this rook a6
oh hello eduardo rook af2
maybe
magnus doesn't make mistakes computer
mistakes i mean i'm not arguing with
that the guy is
god
okay um so in the game anand just went
for e5
now bringing the rook makes sense but
then because this
this size gets like it we can start
pushing pawns
and uh let's see what else was the
suggestion oh f4
possible but again we could just take
that and
uh something like f5 then boom we get to
the other side
hulk oh yeah he did have a very great
tournament
this week there has been so much chess
recently
grand chester is starting soon isn't it
i also know that i was following the the
world cup qualifiers for
um the u.s side of it's the american
side of it too
and i believe the similar one was
happening from the asian ones
yeah i thought that was interesting all
right yeah uh taking is cool if you try
to take
back then i can just try to exchange the
nights and this is a nice new hole for
me to go poke at
all right so rook a6 e5 now what do we
do
is it time for us to play g6 i get this
knight involved
or is that uh is that does it just make
it uh make our king a little weaker
what do we think what peace peace i have
a cat considering to join us nope he
went under the table
well i mean if we're lucky he might
uh we are still so bright now we're kind
of trying to figure out what to do from
black's side because we we went ahead
and we
did this e5 for white so now black
h6 huh
why h6 is becoming so popular
because h6 is a bad move just f4 we're
not going to be able to take that
and we're not going to get this knight
involved and this
rook is also not really doing anything
he tried to play rook g3
not just h4 and one of these palms was
just like a
super pawn march i don't like h6 g6
i think it's doable honestly uh the
issue with g6 could be just simply
f4 and trying to go for f5 that's an
issue that we can't really um
i mean i can't do anything about
but i agree that we need to get this
lines involved
so how do you think we should get this
night involved
g6 just makes the direct move yeah kind
of i agree with that oh there we go nice
e7
so it's not just about trying to do
knights e6 even though i would like to
um let me ask you what about b4 do we
like this
idea of b4
then my only problem with i think g6 is
quite strong my only issue with g6 is
when we play g6
that then we have to do this knight g7
then
the knight is just kind of there and
then the pawn on g6
is a good target practice for h5 and
then like
white to play h4 h5 y2 f5 it just feels
too
heavy
i like b4 too i think it's interested uh
interesting
but the issue is just take take and then
this exchange
now this bishop is a little useless over
here take then your queen gotta go there
too
and uh it's fine but
a little just a little like ah i wish my
position
had more to offer not a very
it doesn't have that many opportunities
i guess that's what i'm trying to say
for black at least yeah
however to be fair this game this
version of the
the attack also doesn't really feel as
strong
as it uh looked for anand in the game
so let's let's see so in the game i
guess enough by b4 he simply played
knight c7
f4 and now he played b4
now in the game take what do we think
about f5
if f5 b3 kind of looks fancy
what do we think about this
to be fair it looks like either white's
gonna just kind of
attack attack attack and win pretty soon
or
uh black's just gonna get away with it
and slowly
um do stuff in the queen side so i think
those are your two
logical options
all right so after the circuit
sorry after this take
take and take take now this night
kind of a little disappointing i was
really hoping it would be on f5
eventually
just so cool here but this knight over
here
is somewhat supporting the spawn
structures as well
so in the game when anand decided to
play f5
now this is another tiny critical
moment you can take you can push
or you can push those are your i want to
say
top three choices so which one should we
go for
taking it looks pretty cool g6 feels a
little
off balance honestly
i do like b3 and b3
um
b3 also seems to be a little
off balance honestly but b3
is what magnus played g6
seems to be the most lovable by the
computer because after g6
if white tries to play e6 that's a whole
different dimension of you they tang at
an
f6 and things can get really weird over
here
however um taking is
also another suggestion
yeah you kind of gotta do it if you're
suspecting to
get a little bit of checkmate all right
so
uh b3 was played in the game
i know right anand did lose this game
but he was like very winning hello hello
do we go we got in the room hello
all right kitty you gotta sit down
somewhere we got a hot spot going for
the game
i'm gonna sit here you good here
no
okay
yeah he's being a good boy
we've had some challenges over the
weekend so
we share that little cutie bond
oh i'm so sorry did he get to the
microphone again
oh boy sorry everybody he does that i
am not able to um anticipate
which direction he's going to jump
it really depends on his mood i tried i
thought i
hit the microphone well i apologize for
anybody's ear damage
he's cute put it on hands put it on his
tap
all right okay okay
let's go back to the uh adam's carson
game if only if they knew there was a
cat here
messing with the audience
what's the logic of b6 since white can't
go before
exactly so it's not about night before
per se it's about
okay if it's more like if i don't get
checkmated
i'm gonna be able to use this
um pawn structures very nicely
soon so that's more about i i think
that's more about it it's not about
um i'm enjoy i'm so much enjoying this
pawn on b3 i don't know what to do with
it
um i'm gonna go karaoke it's not about
that
all right all right so um are you
getting distracted because they're
fluffy creatures around
well i keep getting distracted okay
so i think this b3 was actually a pretty
cool idea that wasn't it's
uh i wish i was strong enough to say i
wouldn't want to take on situ but i'm
very tempted i would want to take on c3
all right after b3 ana simply played
queen f4 at
f6 what do you think about f6
might as well show the audience some
cool stuff said
good boy
yeah we gotta do this g6 right
now after this um
now anant could have tried like with
queen f4
then we got to save this king because uh
huh that's coming up
and then we could push for something
like that
however this is very very scary i
am not very comfortable for this
i think actually queenish six was played
a little too early
anyways this is still doable and this
this is
serious check my threads coming up right
tishi now
what do you think about this should we
make a queena or is this game hopeless
oh
[Music]
i shouldn't be such a good boy all the
time you want to go
okay i think he wants to go maybe not on
the microphone oh
maybe go the other way good boy
yeah that game is eight years old
okay we gotta make this queen and then
okay bishop f1 now what do we do
this move you have one single move
to survive this position
one single move what is that move
no not gonna
stop it from lovely
all right so and uh this is something a
line that could have happened
and now white actually has to
fight for um equality
because right now black does have the
upper hand
so this is i thought this was kind of
cool
all right so that was just like very
deep line that i wanted to show
you can just stop it all and enjoy the
rest of this
however let's go back to the main line
if
so this was the f6 so another line
is if not f6
uh let's see what else could be what
about
knight h5 how do we like that
what about knight h5 it was a kind of a
cool line right
what if night is five at night that's
fine right now it's not really posing a
threat so i can just
oops i can just bring my um knights
right
yeah i can just bring my knight and
just enjoy this a little bit go attack
pawns
i feel like right now i'm just singing i
want to attack this
i want to attack that
yes mish michael it is
yep hello from india
lovely all right so
white is trying to do f6
ideas however it might not be exactly
the brightest idea at the moment so
that's kind of the deal
all right okay
so let's go ahead and take a quick look
at how this
line would end then we could take it
over here if you take then boom
i'm gonna make another queen so for
those of you who kept wondering
why b3 because it kind of paralyzes
bunch of
white's pieces
good morning whoa where are you nick all
right it's rookie of one and then you
can eat that and that's also super
winning
all righty let's go back to the main
line so
in the real game remember this line with
f6 g6 queen f4 that we just looked at
so anand made an improvement and he just
pushed
queen f4 first so after queen f4
knight c7 anand went for f6
okay so question what to do white
black to move
everybody good we're almost done with
the scan there's like five more moves
left
actually last four more moves left
i think pushing is a good idea this g6 i
like it
[Music]
what else do we have
i think this idea with g6 could be very
beneficial
because
let's see what else do we have on it
yeah i mean
there is a suggestion of taking but this
is
way too computer move it just makes my
brain go
no no like no i don't know i don't want
to bother
if there's g6 i'm not going to do that
yeah knight e6 also doable
after knight e6 queen f3
could be played then we could do g6 yeah
doable very doable too but then this is
a weakness so but just be careful on
that
if you know you're going to do g6 just
do g6 and be done with it
now in the game alan's played queen h4
this is a
very very critical position now black to
move what to do
this move really did blow my mind
you have two choices either you gotta
move this king and then the queen comes
and then you bring the rook and you deal
with that because
this is a very serious checkmate threat
or
you try to um
make a small difference
no not tonight's e6 if knight e6
queen h6 can happen and then this is a
serious problem
yeah no no h5 no i
just knight can take honestly
thank you thank you knight e8 good job
98 is a very strong move
right
all right so we got this out of the way
yeah knight is 98
uh and in the game
white continued with queen h6 so
after queen h6 there's no serious
stretch of checkmates right
now but there is threats
of uh whoops happening over here
so black to move what to do i'll give
you
a choice well actually if i i don't want
to
give spoilers
i really want to give you a choice but i
don't want to give you spoilers
yeah b2 good job
lovely
yeah b2 again i kind of did spoil it
earlier sorry guys
yes so this prevents
any touching of rook you touch her you
touch your rook i'll make a queen
you can't touch your rook so that's
that's uh that's off limits
um white does have good
uh ideas so it's not like why it's
completely hopeless not white could do
92
why it could do i think 92 is a big one
and if okay let me tell you what happens
with rook f4 let's start with that
rook four is actually what happened in
the game but
what do you think about that what do you
think about rook f4
we should make that queen right because
he's going for serious checkmates so we
make the queen
and then anand made the horrible mistake
he played knight f1
so can you tell me what's different
between knight f1 and bishop f1
oh well we'll address rook b1 at knight
e2 in a second i just want to
show you this mistake
white black has two queens
so bishop f1 is the good move
even if we do like queen d1 like last
time that
we had this similar position rookie
short finish five
boom bam then take then the bishop comes
up
there's a white still holds a good
counter play because
of something like g6 now you take now
rook g5 it's just
this knight has to stay here this
bishop's stuck here this trick is stuck
because of this like everything is just
stuck and to top that
off um now if black tries to free
himself
again this pond falls there is like so
much weakness around that i don't think
it's um
most likely gonna end the draw basically
yeah
basically yeah so that's the thing
magnus is not
winning if anand made the right choice
of playing bishop f1
anand made a mistake he played knight f1
so what do we think about that
what's wrong with knight f1 exactly
thank you queenie one
and this queen e1 stops rookish for
anand immediately resigned if you played
ricochet i'm just gonna eat that
and i just just have an extra rook
that's enough
yeah he made a horrible mistake
now we know how the game ended but let
me um
let me do this and start in the rook
what's wrong with drug b1
first off if rook b1 i can just do like
queen a5 attack over here i want to do
queen a1
2 so that's the biggest problem
uh if knight e2 i think knight t2 is
another one
worth considering but it kind of makes
the game a little chill we can just do
like a chill bishop e6
if you do knight f4 then i can do it
show queen a5
kind of just like because white's not
exactly attacking anything
gives black a chance to free the queen
even though it's just to clean on that
pawn on v2 it's still
enough forces to steer up
some heat i guess that's the right
expression
yeah so that's what we are going for
all right any other question for this
game
i really think it was so sad that like
anand made
so many accurate news and one move and
it all goes
same way gmt she runs out of the door
whenever doors open
yeah oh
exxon feel free to send me an email or
contact me via instagram that's one of
the things that
i do check
yeah it was a sad win bittersweet
bittersweet
we love magnus we can't i cannot really
do i cannot
such a calm personality just like
if i see him i feel like i'm listening
to one of my discs on
how to be relaxed and then i want to do
yoga oh
that'll get that's very fun all right so
um
that's all the thing i have for this
game so now
we if there are no questions for this
segment of the class
we are going to do the switch to twitch
and yeah so we're going to do
our segment upstairs to twitch uh please
have
so what we do is we go on twitch you'll
share your games
uh via leeches link either games unleash
us
that you play there you import your
games only chess and then you will
join us on twitch channel
just steal chess club and you will share
your games
there so we are going to do that in
about 10 minutes i'm gonna do a short
get more tea switch from youtube to
twitch
shouldn't take more than that uh i'll
see you in 10 minutes
so please have your game ready it's more
of a first come first serve
type of deal but if you are a subscriber
you will be prioritized too so
i'll see you in about 10 minutes have a
great